let's pull this up from the daily beast
crazy mike lindell fed seized my cell
phone at hardy's at hardee's hearties
where's this guy can a man enjoy a
burger where is he just near hearties
lindell also posted a subpoena on what
appears to be a search warrant
so this is breaking news my pillow's ceo
mike lindell told the daily beast on
tuesday night that the fbi seized his
cell phone while he was at a hardy's
restaurant he posted on social media a
grand jury subpoena from a federal
prosecutor in colorado who appears to be
a search warrant the fbi no immediate
comment
so well i don't know man what else can
be said
it's it's it's it's the system's busted
it's falling apart they are looking to
do what they did to nixon and all of his
uh crew and his cohorts you know we're
right now we're doing a multiple part
series on nixon and it's fascinating the
parallels between what's happening in
that right now with trump and all the
trump circle and what happened to nixon
back in the day and the more that they
can dirty everyone that's around him
they scare people from getting involved
within the community within his culture
within within his uh
circle of politics they they dirty him
up to be able to go and and run for a
next election i think that's what this
entire thing is about it's the narrative
machine in action scare everybody that's
associated with trump he's gonna have a
hard time getting good people because of
that
constantly paint him and any associate
that he has as a criminal you don't
think that we're gonna see perp walk uh
ads ads when the when election comes oh
yeah we are going to see perp walk ads
they are going and i said this uh back
in the jan six time frame that trump
we're going to see trump perp walked and
people thought it was nuts when i said
that oh yeah it's not going to happen he
is going to get perp walked they want
that image so they could put it whether
it stands or not it doesn't whether it
doesn't matter it's the image we got a
video here we got a video here of uh
mike lindell
so uh we will play this video i think
this might be the video today the fbi
all right let's let's quiet let's quiet
that down a little bit mike you're
pretty loud
sorry about that
today the fbi
uh you're gonna hear this and you're
probably already hearing in the news the
fbi
came after me and took my phone they
surrounded me at a hardee's
and uh took my phone i run all my
business everything with um
they could have just what they've done
is weaponized the fbi um
it's disgusting i don't have a computer
everything i do have that phone
everything was on there and uh
um
and they told me not to tell anybody
here's an order not to don't tell
anybody okay i won't
i am
so
they perp walked steve bannon over a
million bucks yep blm's been accused of
stealing more than that the the leaders
the founders and stuff like that uh
nothing in the and wasn't he pardoned i
mean uh how is that we're in a civil war
so uh
you know what no no i should take that
back we're in a revolution civil war
implies that there's factions fighting
each other but right now the fbi is just
rounding people up and it's and it
appears to be extra legal yeah there's
an attempted revolution from the liberal
world order to the new world order i
gotta say that clearly liberal world
order to a new world order and that
seems like some people in the american
government are complicit
i mean i don't have proof i just seems
like that's that's that's that's a bit
beyond where i'm at i'm just saying the
democrats don't want to lose they want
power they're scared of trump and
they've weaponized the doj to go after
anybody who might help trump we saw this
in 2018 when the big tech company
started banning prominent influencers
who helped trump win notably alex jones
they purged him all the exact same time
alex jones is now on trial again
for defamation and it's like it seems to
be going the same way they're like oh
you're not a lot of defense and things
like that you're you're refusing to you
know send out you know to turn over
proper information now they're going
after steve bannon there's 35
prominent trump supporters you know
dark days is an understatement if
i don't i don't know what happens
but typically when you look at history
and you see things like this
we're looking at probably something more
like a bolshevik style revolution i mean
maybe maybe that's that's that's
too much but what's likely more likely
than civil war at this point is just
uniparty arrests the purging of
political rivals the evisceration of
anyone who's supporting the ideology and
just a totalitarian uniparty so you know
you can have a civil war when two
factions fight over control of one
government or in the united states it
was one faction trying to leave a
government or you have a revolution
where one group seizes control uses it
to immediately purge and wipe out their
opponents and then take over
tucker carlson called this a full-blown
political purge
and he he's not wrong i mean look at
what's happening here i mean what what
what will the mike my pillow guy do to
you what kind of threat is he to you who
is he going to hurt what did he do what
did he do what did he get away with he's
got money i know but but from the
average person watching this who's not
into politics seeing this right now a
lot of people are asking themselves this
question obviously this is very
political but but they're still trying
to say that this is this is somehow
justified that the doj is going after
bad people that they're going after
criminals but there's not even a shred
of evidence to suggest this because from
the average point of view
what effect is he having like what did
they steal something no they didn't they
didn't get away with anything were they
able to to to lie or cheat and no they
don't there's no there's nothing of that
i think this is a large fishing
operation i think they're looking for
whatever they could get and
going through someone's phone going
through someone's self cell phones and
laptops and computers and all of their
documents they're just hoping someone
slipped up and made some kind of mistake
and if they did we're going to be
hearing about it till the end of days
now seems like oh and they're also
trying to scare advertisers as well too
he's one of the biggest kind of
advertiser known advertiser on the right
funds a lot of different shows a lot of
different podcasts and they're trying to
send a message out there as well that
you know if you guys try to enter into
this arena if you guys try to appeal to
the right we're going to come at you a
lot of people don't we don't talk about
this so much but how how completely
leftist the advertising community is
they they have control the digital
platforms that are that distribute these
advertisements they've gotten
conservative
websites kicked off of these uh
advertising networks for years and years
and years so there's so many different
things kind of in play here they want
everyone that's trying to touch trump to
look dirty they want to scare
advertisers to scare away funding for
shows uh it's it's a really a smart play
if you think about it these people that
we're dealing with are not stupid they
understand the imagery they understand
what it means to have obannon walk to
akshamiban and walk down perp walked
they understand the power of the imagery
they've been doing this since this since
the civil rights era getting pictures of
you know dogs in front of civil rights
activists and and hoses being shot on
them so i think that's what what this
is doing they're they're they're feeding
their narrative machine with this stuff
so that they can scare the the right
yeah i was getting the sense that it's
the people that were saying that the
election was stolen and that they have
proof but like then the proof never came
out and they're like it's coming just
wait three months and then it'll be
there lindell and bannon are really hard
on that they're really bush um but what
i don't get is who cares like let him
say it like that's part of democracy
we're allowed to yell stuff at each
other biden's the president let's secure
the elections by having open source
voting systems they did it for four
years with the russians with the russian
accusations with trump when trump
won and and now like
i just it's just mind-boggling to see
what's happening here because it's so
dangerous for everyone involved here i
wasn't a trump supporter i didn't i
didn't back him i criticized him but but
still it doesn't matter to a lot of
people because now even calling this out
automatically labels me as some kind of
trump supporter when i'm not that's the
point that and that's the other side of
it is i was ready to walk um be past
trump i was a trump supporter i was
ready to be done
then all this stuff starts to hit and
all they're doing is pulling these
people out that were done with him and
ready to move on to a desantis or what
have you they're pulling them back in
they pulled me back in
in that regard
i'm not sure if it's the right play or
but they they think they know what
they're doing
like scratching
administration has politicized law
enforcement to the point
where it feels soviet and we were not
overstating it the fbi has just raided
the guy who sells pillows on this
channel not because the pillows were bad
but because they don't like what we
voted for it'd be funny if the fbi was
like well the pillows actually are
really good use promo code
use promo code fbi yeah promo code gulag
reports on his live stream lindell tv
that fbi agents located him questioned
him showed him their badges and asked
him questions about colorado and
dominion voting machines and then
provided him with a warrant to seize his
cell phone
and he says uh we're fbi i said show me
your badges
so they showed one bad and they said how
about yours you know i'm you know can i
don't trust anybody like you know
there's bad people well they do that and
they said what do you want
and uh says we need to talk to you so i
pull over
and uh
mike lindell said he initially told
those agents he would not surrender his
phone because he does not have a
computer and runs all of his businesses
off of that phone lindell published on
his live stream what he claims was the
warrant for that phone we do not have
lindell's account confirmed right now
but we will be looking into it and
keeping you updated tucker
so maybe it's maybe it's bunk i don't
know but um i kind of believe the pillow
guy
like this is a story i don't think he
just makes up especially considering
bannon came out said 35 people were hit
then we got official confirmation that
40 subpoenas had been sent out the
subpoenas probably included mike lindell
why wouldn't they i mean he's one of the
most vocal supporters of donald trump he
also funded didn't he fund some kind of
a program to look into the election
fraud and what have you he did a big
symposium or something about it tucker
actually talked about the people who are
named on that list last night and he
talked about one person who organized a
rally and how the fbi raided the
daughter of this person who organized a
rally and how
they weren't even involved in politics
they were already involved in
politicians they were just someone
involved in uh getting people to do
political rallies and they are the they
were the ones that were raided by fbi
officials coming at their door knocking
on their door and of course
intervening in their life and watching
every single move they make very
carefully and you know the information
especially with how the dog has been
recently handling it most likely is
going to be leaked to the media as of
course there's a lot of things that
routinely are not supposed to make it
out there to the general public through
these investigations that do that smear
people that attack people there's phone
records there's text messages there's
there's things about individuals
personal lives that always make it out
there and this is the weaponization of
the doj that of course um is going out
there and going after people that they
don't like because of their political
opinions and ideas i don't even agree
with those political opinions and ideas
but this is such a dangerous move
because it endangers everyone here this
is meant to set a chilling factor
and uh it is scaring some people
if you ever wondered what it was like to
be living in uh you know any one of
these historical nations before the
emergence of the
authoritarian regimes be it north korea
or weimar germany or russia or china or
whatever you're living in it
this is how it starts
and uh man i really gotta wonder i
wonder if um
the coveted lockdowns were kind of uh
a dry run will people submit to
unconstitutional lockdowns in the
destruction of their lives and they
found the answer was yes overwhelmingly
it was nuts how the roman republic just
turned into an empire you go from a
republic to an empire that seems really
extreme i was just reading about the
british monarchy and the king you know
it's hot topic right now and like
he can take control he can disband
parliament
i mean
they say he won't because elizabeth
never did but he can and all he's got to
do is claim emergency but like what's an
emergency a flood an earthquake uh
someone saying the wrong thing on social
media spilling your tea
yeah the way they use the word emergency
these days like how many emergency acts
has biden
uh going right now we have like 45
states of emergency or some we were
looking up some numbers some over like
25 or current um
yeah yeah tons of emergencies mostly
foreign policy i think yeah and some of
it's like about iraq you're like what
the hell we've been out of iraq like
what emergency are we as american
citizens facing because of what's
happening in that country and so if they
if the king were to seize power and
become the the sole monarch of england
all of britain all of a sudden and then
they they try and emulate that over here
with try yeah i know they're doing
disturbing it doesn't
but i mean it's not it's totally
possible it's feasible that's the
problem california is still in a state
of emergency to this day
it's it still has that because they do
not want to relinquish the power the
second that they were able to imp
implement this power this power grab and
we've seen it time and time again
anytime these you know the bushes did it
with the patriot act anytime these power
this power is given to the government
they never let go of it and the thing
that's been the difference is is that
the right is not as good at enforcing
their their power the left is our
masters at it they have figured out ways
to be able to
to use the government in ways that
they've accused trump of doing when
trump was in office thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there